each of them are just fun silly things
and there are more what the hell is that
a dress says who calvin klein i could
call paul read and ask his daughter if
she'll be done with me
in business do you have a business it's
also a club the babysitter's club the
babysitter's club is just so sweet
alicia how would you describe season two
for all those parents out there i think
watching it with your kid if you have i
think people watch it but even if they
don't have to be honest but the ones who
watch it with their children it's just
such a nice awesome thing to do there's
no whining and complaining it's these
are empowered characters they're trying
to find their way in the world and they
have such different points of view such
different backgrounds and different
issues and complications to sort through
and it's just i think everyone can see
themselves up there we are in this
together girl no we are not it's really
high stakes but through all the problems
the friends are always there for each
other so the basic message is let's take
care of each other through this tough
world that you know everyone from
parents like alicia and me and kids
growing up into this world are dealing
oh
i need to give you major props because
your tick-tock game is so strong and
watching you do these reenactments of
iconic clueless scenes has been so much
fun with your son with christian siriano
how do those moments come about and do
you have other scenes that are in the
works i was forced into it well we did
them so quickly the one that we did the
very first kickback that i did my son
had been talking about the truck for a
long time
when i kept saying no no no no and
finally i gave in and thought it would
be really fun and also a way to get
people over to my causes that i really
care about you know on the tying diet
the kind mama the kind likes so that's
obviously my main motivation but fair
and i it took us like three minutes to
make that one my friend christian said
why are you wearing that nurse's outfit
underneath the jacket and is it because
i wasn't thinking about it i just had it
that's what i was wearing and i shoved
the jacket on each of them are just fun
silly things and there are more
projects
would you ever want to get back together
with any of your clueless co-stars to
reenact a scene good i have bear i have
the dog you know i'm fine or they're
kids you could just find their kids and
reenact it with your co-stars children
that would be good i could call paul
rudd and ask his daughter if she'll be
done with me want to practice parking
what's the point everywhere you go has
valet i do love how much bear does love
all of your projects clueless especially
is he the one who's really pressing for
you to ever do like some kind of
clueless reboot or revival well bear's
favorite project i ever did as he says
on the tick tock no babysitter stuff
babies and stuff i love the show so much
he loves mark he loves looking great he
loves being on set he loves all of it
and he loves it in such a neat way
because he doesn't want to be an actor
not interested i was gonna say would you
let him cameo he is in season two where
you're gonna see well we can't give
everything away but you're gonna see
season two where was he this scene when
there's the episode about ac scala event
that we all go to he is there he's papa
docking
lenny linney papadakis then he stopped
attacking yup mom is buying trying to
buy the bassinet stuff and he's and he's
standing there oh my gosh
and he's so good and and he's such the
life of the party whenever he's on set
like everyone gravitates to him and he's
like best friends with every single
member of the cast everyone loves him
more love is always a happy thing trust
us food now
we're
say hello to babysitters
friends